mich hat heute sehr beschäftigt die
riesige kluft zwischen meiner
wahrnehmung dieses tri ace und der
umfrage die danach veröffentlicht worden
ist ich hab' armin laschet klar vorne
gesehen er war lebendig angriffslustig
und hat dort die themen gesetzt muss ich
mal sagen im wesentlichen jedenfalls und
olaf scholz erschien mir das soll ich
sagen eingeschlafen und extrem
langweilig selbst wenn man kennt wie er
normalerweise argumentiert und dann sehe
ich die umfrage also arbeitet mir völlig
sicher der laschet hat das gewonnen
überraschender maßen muss ich sagen dann
kommt die umfrage scholz 36 laschet 25
darstellt das ist für mich nicht eine
lehrreiche geschichte und für die cdu
eine ganz bittere denn da kann man
daraus lernen dass der größte teil der
wähler für laschet nicht mehr
ansprechbar ist das ist vorbei das ist
gelaufen er erwischt sie nicht mehr da
muss die da muss die partei konsequenzen
daraus ziehen und wir haben heute noch
zwei dinge erlebt die das ganze noch
zuspitzen laschet eine pressekonferenz
gegeben über klimapolitik
extrem langweilig keine neuen themen
gesetzt und das ganze mit drei
sogenannten experten die kein mensch
kennt der der thomas heilmann aus berlin
bundestagsabgeordneter den kennt man
unter journalist uns schon ein bisschen
aber an der breiten bevölkerung kennt
ihn überhaupt niemand da macht also der
kanzlerkandidat der ein thema vorstellen
will und voranbringen will in der
pressekonferenz mit unbekannten das
nennt er sein team das will er jetzt
glaube ich noch vier mal mit anderen
themen machen und zwar mit genau solchen
leuten das reitet ihn immer weiter
runter weil die leute immer weiter
enttäuscht sind von ihm und der zweite
punkt ist es kam der neue umfang ist
glaube ich eure von bild gewesen dass
die cdu jetzt bei 20 prozent liegt und
die spd bei 25 also die die die lücke
öffnet sich immer mehr für die union es
gibt auch erste hinweise darauf dass
bald die nächste umfrage kommt wonach
die union unter 20 prozent liegt das
erste mal und da muss ich sagen
da hört der spaß auf die cdu muss sich
jetzt vor dem eigenen kandidaten
schützen das entscheidende ist er muss
sich schützen lassen mich das noch ein
noch zwei sätze dazufügen dass das heißt
sie muss ihnen sofort kippen oder sie
muss ich mit den wahlkampf aus der hand
nehmen und diese forderung richtet sich
insbesondere in beiden fällen an die
ministerpräsidenten der union dann
niemand anders kann das machen die
müssen sich kurzschließen und über reden
wie sie mit dem problem umgehen sonst
vernichten sie die cdu das spannende was
wir gestern noch gesehen haben und wir
haben ja glaube ich alle das trial
geguckt und wir hatten alle das gefühl
dass die performance von armin laschet
und die umfragen oder dass diese umfrage
nicht wirklich in einklang standen mein
eindruck ist inzwischen eher und dass
wir in der tat verheerend für die union
das ist sozusagen sozial erwünschtes
verhalten ist das kennen wir aus
umfragen gegen armin laschet zustimmen
man traut sich in manchen milieus gar
nicht mehr zu sagen der war aber gut so
wir ja am ende war man kann sagen es war
ausgeglichen scholz leicht vorne laschet
leicht vorne aber ganz sicher war es
nicht so wie das haar und will das sagen
wie das da gestern in den umfrage
auftaucht ich glaube dass armin laschet
in der situation ist dass er inzwischen
der einzige ist dennoch an sich glaubt
wenn überhaupt und das ist das problem
weil es die wähler potenziellen wähler
auch die kernklientel der union angeht
irgendwie schon darüber geredet aber ich
finde fast noch schlimmer auch innerhalb
der union
also ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen
dass gar keiner mehr mit ihm ins team
will weil es nämlich ein team ist es
noch auf den abgrund zusteuert das ist
sozusagen ein
skiflieger der möglicherweise gar kein
stadion unter sich hat irgendwo überm
wald oder dem der schlucht ist die frage
kann aber wieder kann er da wieder
rauskommen ich kann aber da wieder
rauskommen kann armin laschet diese wahl
mit diesen umfragen diesem persönlichen
werten noch mal würde ich sagen nichts
ist unmöglich aber da ist jetzt der zug
abgefahren als hat ist uns klar geworden
weil wir dem trainer ich glaube das kann
in diesem fall überhaupt gar nichts
sagen also noch mal wenn man sechs
wochen zurück denken oder so wieder
wahlkampf gestartet ist mit den grünen
den sonstigen erhöhen dann die union was
30 prozent oder so also ich würde jetzt
vier wochen voller war noch gar nichts
sagen wir wissen nicht welche skandalen
auf den tisch kommen aber ich stehe
absolut zu dass armin laschet einen
entscheidenden vorteil nicht hat nämlich
dass die partei hinter ihm steht mir so
gar nicht so zu etwas wirklich sehr
erstaunlich ist und wenn am last das in
den griff kriegt oder zumindest sein
team ich glaube auch das ist düster
ausstellung haben ich bin ein schritt
weiter die steht nicht nur hinter ihm
sondern eher gefährdet seine partei das
ist natürlich bei einem kandidaten sehr
selten das sind partei gefährdet und der
reißt sie jetzt richtung unterwegs sein
vorsitzender warnung heraus dass
irgendwann schafft auch zu spielen was
er irgendwie in seinem bundesland
schafft nämlich an den zu haben das sehr
diverse ist und sehr unter die
positionen besetzt so hätte dort zu
arbeiten sollte doch in den wahlkampf
gehen können also mit wirklich
unterschiedlichsten personen aber jetzt
dann führte dass sie vermutlich zu sehr
friedrich merz auch ins traten nicht zu
rücken weil vielleicht zu wirtschafts
brutal egal ich finde das wäre der
moment gewesen das zu machen so ich bin
nicht nur das sondern ich bin ein team
so wir sind die breite mitte dass er
kann aber nicht warten bis zum nächsten
triumph 14 tagen hin zu viel also sonst
verwirklichen die noch was sowieso nicht
geschafft hat die union muss sich jetzt
schnell ausgeführter nächsten tagen muss
was passieren entweder neben sie im
wahlkampf aus der hand oder sie gibt
abgeholt oder so da die fdp sagt wenn
das so weiter lernen müssen wir in die
hand geben
das ist nicht unsere aufgabe die union
muss selber verfahren das könnt ihr
nochmal motivationsschub verein
motivieren muss herr laschet seine
truppen selbst aber jetzt ist die zeit
dafür aber ist also nächstes trier sind
zwei wochen genau das reichen dies
musste hier die strategie von armin
laschet war ja eigentlich zu sagen ich
drehe das ding in den tri allen das
scheint ja eher schwierig zu werden naja
es gibt ja eine umfrage jetzt auch eine
zweite umfrage nicht nur vorsah mit
diesen bekannten werden der drei
kandidaten zu hause noch eine zweite von
zwei für
wie heißt der laden brauche ich in
business insider ja als der
wasserspiegel oder ne wurst wer heute
herausgekommen danach sagen 72 der
menschen sie können sich nicht
vorstellen dass laschet die die richtung
dreht das sind drei viertel der wähler
die die gar nicht mehr hinhören die ihr
urteil gefällt haben das ist das drama
vier wochen ich bin wetter echt was soll
passieren also es sind noch vier wochen
stimmt das ist ungefähr die
optimistische satz nehmen man im moment
aus dem laschet lager hört aber was soll
denn viel passiert müssen etwas anders
den hornets wieder stärkste kraft wird
aber es reicht wenn das ding wie
stabilisieren nicht so hart zurückfallen
und mit den grünen und der fdp nach
jamaika zusammen bringen würden das
würde ja schon reichen von politischer
so geht es doch nicht da müssen dann
allerdings mit dabei sein die sich in
die büsche geschlagen haben ist doch
keine aufgabe
wenn er nicht stärkste partei wird dann
ist ja olaf scholz am zug und der bedarf
der eigentlichen grünen was machen uns
schon geht die perspektive
sieht dann muss die fdp dafür sorgen
dass nicht alles ganz nach links rutscht
und in die ampel gehen insofern die
frage kultshow das ist sechs tage die
ich mir die ganze zeit steht aber
erstmal die fdp verantwortung bei der
union selbst absolut sie gehörte müssen
wir
achtsamer und sondern selber ein angebot
zu machen aber ich frage mich ja schon
immer wie das für die liberalen oder wie
das innen liberalen aussieht wenn es
jetzt die patriotische pflicht wäre
für die fdp rot rot grün zu verhindern
indem man in die ampel geht
das machen sind dann gehen rein erstmal
sind jetzt vier wochen
sind wirklich drei wörter es geht jetzt
es geht jetzt darum die
auseinandersetzung zu führen also hier
wird sozialismus aus der mottenkiste
geholt jeden tag und die union er ist
olaf scholz sozialist aus der
mottenkiste die ideen die jeden tag hoch
war aber nicht nur von olaf scholz auch
von den grünen übrigens die erfinder für
schöne begriffe aber das ist alter wein
in was ist neu texte sozialisten idee
die da gerade auf dem markt ist und uns
frisch verpackt der mieten der gäste das
einzige da ist eine menge im köcher und
bisher kommt das macht wie viel zu wenig
zur sprache sie werden doch sicher sagen
der lokhalle demokraten nützen
miteinander gespräche aber vorher müssen
sind
denn die müssen das beste für
deutschland raus wo in wählerwillen
müssen wir die kräfteverhältnisse
beeinflussen wir glauben ist eine auf
vier wochen die fdp will gegen die ampel
gehen um rot rot grün zu verhindern also
vom tisch der clan zeichen anzeichen
sie lagen nein ich stimme nicht abhängig
kämpfen
aber nochmal um auf den punkt zurück zu
kommen also ob die trendwende noch
möglich ist gibt es nur zwei
möglichkeiten entweder die stärke des
kandidaten laschet wird bemerkenswerter
das ist nicht erkennbar im gegenteil
oder das geht auch der kontrahent
schwächelt aber olaf scholz stärke ja
auch nicht also erst geld nicht
erschwert nicht ermittelt sich so durch
und deswegen glaube ich dass wohl
erstmals dass es reichen kann olaf
scholz sagt inzwischen ja auch in den
tälern vollkommen offen die kanzlerin
und ich wünschen und jaja so langsam wie
enthält er ist ja man auch daran dass er
ständig über sein gehalt spricht ja also
er sagt es ist praktisch er sagt ich
habe 250.000 euro kann man hier
nachlesen umgesetzt
und so weiter weißt du nicht was der
benzinpreis ist oder wie hoch der
benzinpreis er ist völlig er ist er ist
ich glaube er glaubt jetzt selber